تريد أن تكون
مركزًا إقليميًا رائدًا إقليميًا ما الذي تحتاجه
لذلك
نحن حاليًا رواد إقليمي
في تطوير التكنولوجيا
إذا استبعدت إسرائيل على سبيل المثال ،
ونحن رواد إقليمي من حيث
جذب الاستثمارات من جميع أنحاء
العالم إلى منطقتنا  شركات الاقتصادات الرقمية
من أصل 2.73 مليار
دولار تم استثمارها في الشرق الأوسط في عام
2021 ،
جاءت 51 إلى الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، لذا فهي توضح لك
مدى الإثارة حول
هذا التحدي الذي نواجهه اليوم هو
حجم السوق بحجم  السوق
في الإمارات العربية المتحدة رائع ولكنه ليس كبيرًا بالقدر
الذي نريده لهؤلاء المنافسين ،
فما هو السوق الذي تبحث عنه ، لذلك نحن
لا ننظر فقط إلى السوق الإقليمي
الذي نتطلع إليه لإنشاء
شركات عالمية من  الإمارات العربية المتحدة التي
تتوسع حقًا لتشمل بقية العالم ،
كان لدينا بعض الأمثلة التي أعتقد أنها
رائعة ، لذا فإن موقع media.net على سبيل المثال الذي تم
شراؤه من قبل كونسورتيوم في عام 2017
كان عملاقًا إعلانيًا عالميًا يساوي 100
مليون  الدولارات ولكننا نريد المزيد
من هذه الأمثلة ،
صديقك
الجديد
في المنطقة ،
إسرائيل ،
هل
يمكنك التخطيط لتعاون أكبر ،
إنه ليس سؤالًا ، إنه بيان
أنك تخطط لتعاون أكبر مع
إسرائيل
كوسيلة للحصول على هذا النفوذ الذي
تمثله إسرائيل  شريك رائع ولكن
عليك أن تفهم أيضًا الاتجاه الجديد
الذي تتخذه دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة كدولة
من منظور دبلوماسي ، فنحن
نحاول أن نصبح سويسرا
الشرق الأوسط ، ما يستلزم ذلك هو أننا نعمل
مع الجميع ونضمن أننا نقدم
قيمة للجميع  كذلك ، إذا استخدمت
إسرائيل كمثال ، فإن إسرائيل هي
مثال رائع لدولة ناشئة ،
أمة يخلق فيها شعبها
مخرجات لا تصدق ، لكن كيف
يمكننا تحقيق التنوع الذي
لدينا 200 جنسية والقدرة على
جذب الناس من جميع أنحاء  العالم
ليأتي إلى الإمارات العربية المتحدة ويكون له قيمة مضافة
لإسرائيل بينما يتعلم في نفس الوقت
من إسرائيل ويخلق مثل هذه الأشياء
فوق دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة التي يمكن
xpand وتصبح عالميًا من حيث الذكاء الاصطناعي
والتكنولوجيا ، هل ترى أن إسرائيل
شريك مستقبلي مهم للوصول إلى هذا الهدف من
الشركات العالمية القائمة أساسًا
في المنطقة ،
لذلك إذا كنت تتحدث تحديدًا
عن المنطقة ،
فإننا نرى في الواقع كل
دولة على حدة  من حولنا كدولة لديها
فرصة لنا ويمكننا تقديم
شيء ما إلى الطاولة إذا
تحدثت عنه عالميًا بالمناسبة ، فإن
إسرائيل لاعب مهم للغاية
ولكننا أيضًا نجري محادثات مع سنغافورة
عندما تتحدث مع كندا  معنا
مع المملكة المتحدة والصين وغيرها ونريد
التأكد من أن لدينا نهجًا غير متحيز
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالعمل مع
الجميع لدفع الظرف أولاً عندما
يتعلق الأمر بتطوير الذكاء الاصطناعي وثانيًا
تحقيق فائدة مشتركة لكلا البلدين